[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy Facebook now takes down around
288 thousand posts every month that it
deems to be hate speech it no one knows
exactly what they consider to be hate
speech susan Benesh director of the
dangerous speech project commented
Facebook is regulating more human speech
than any government does now or ever has
there like a de facto body of law yet
that law is a secret however one aspect
of Facebook censorship is quite clear
Facebook considers opposition to jihad
terror to be hate speech and has begun
to move aggressively against foes of
jihad terror and mass Muslim migration
in the West in early February 2017 they
came for me on February 7th 2017
referrals to my website jihad watch from
Facebook number twenty three thousand
seven hundred and eighty three and from
Twitter 1718 these numbers were
generally representative referrals from
Facebook for several years up to that
point had averaged between 15,000 and
20,000 a day and 1,500 to 2,000 a day
from Twitter but on February 10th 2017
those numbers dropped suddenly and
precipitously with only two thousand
nine hundred twenty three referrals from
Facebook and 295 from Twitter that's
around where they've held since then now
did thousands of people who used to
click through to jihad watch articles
from Facebook and Twitter suddenly lose
interest On February 10th 2017 of course
not what really happened on that day was
that Facebook and Twitter began to
censor jihad watch as hate speech why
did they do this because Facebook is
given assurances to the European Union
that it would crack down on aid speech
and as far as the European Union is
concerned hate speech is any opposition
to their globalist agenda and policy of
appeasement and accommodation for
Islamic supremacists of course it's
absurd that reporting on jihad activity
in Sharia oppression constitutes a
speech but that is the long-standing
claim of the Organization of Islamic
Cooperation and Muslim groups in the
West and it has been uncritically
adopted by the left with which Facebook
and Twitter are so firmly aligned
Facebook's
vice president Joel Kaplan even traveled
to Pakistan in July 2017 to assure the
Pakistani government that it would
remove anti Islam material this is at
heart of Sharia endeavor an Islamic
supremacists attempt to compel the West
to adopt Sharia blasphemy laws
forbidding criticism of Islam and it's
working well since Islamic groups in the
United States and around the world have
always insisted that honest analysis of
the motivating ideology of Islamic Jihad
ease was anti Islam this amounts to
Facebook agreeing that it would remove
all counter jihad material and allowed
jihadists to operate unopposed and
unimpeded they're doing all this with
the protection of the US government as
well in July 2016 the American freedom
Law Center acting on behalf of pamela
geller and others including me filed a
federal lawsuit in the US District Court
for the District of Columbia challenging
section 230 of the Communications
Decency Act under the First Amendment in
a press release the AFL C explained that
section 230 provides immunity from
lawsuits to Facebook Twitter and YouTube
thereby permitting these social media
giants to engage in government
sanctioned censorship and discriminatory
business practices free from legal
challenge as the ASL C explained that we
were often subject to censorship and
discrimination by Facebook Twitter and
YouTube because of our beliefs and views
which Facebook Twitter and YouTube
consider expression that is offensive to
Muslims such discrimination which is
largely religion based in that these
California businesses are favoring
adherents of Islam over those who are
not is prohibited in many states but
particularly in California
by the state's anti-discrimination law
which was broadly construed to prohibit
all forms of discrimination however
because of the immunity granted by the
federal government Facebook Twitter and
YouTube are free to engage in their
otherwise unlawful discriminatory
practices meanwhile Facebook's Sharia
compliance only underscores the
necessity to boycott and disempower the
social media platform and others such as
Twitter that are kowtow to leftists and
Islamic supremacists and banning foes of
jihad terror if Facebook and Twitter
shut out the truth then we have to shut
out Facebook and Twitter I'm Robert
sting
[Music]